Jordan Bardel Asmeka or Gabriel Atal,
the reality is that if Marine Le Pen was elected
President of the Republic,
bah,
France will leave the European Union.
And it is our young people who want to make 1 irasmus
who could no longer do so.
This is all the people who work in
sectors that are closely related to tourism,
that are related to exports
who will be penalized.
If Marine Le Pen is elected,
there will be nothing for the environment.
She even wants to
remove the wind turbines that are in France,
It means that we will open coal-fired power plants,
that is,
we will bring more oil,
more gas.
If Marine Le Pen is elected,
it is not the values of the Republic
that will be defended
because its priority,
is to ask the police to go,
uh.
Running the women who wear the veil,
yes,
to remove their veil or to verbalize them.
It's in. Well,
it's in these proposals,
because his priority is to tell children,
to young people who were born in France,
who will have to be evicted from their social housing
because their parents
are not French
and the sun will not rise anymore.
No, it's in the program.
There will be avalanches,
tsunamis,
It's going to be horrible.
You react like this
to disqualify,
I did not interrupt you.
But in the program of Marine Le Pen,
there is 1 measure called the national priority.
Page 9,
in her family booklet,
she. Says,
we will be able to returnsix-cent-vingt-mille housing
in which there are foreign families,
by expelling them,
to give them back to French families,
of course.
Well, yes, it's written,
it's written on page 9,
in real families,
anyone can go.
We're going to get people out.
Well yes,
we will die
quickly these accommodations
in which there are foreign families,
foreigners who are there in a regular situation,
who work,
who have children,
who were born in France.
You want to get them out of their home.
Is this your program?
It is not the values of the Republic.
And we defend the values of the Republic.